Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
In the last few videos we've been talking about life on the moons of gas shine,
so we have to wonder,
could life exists on a gas giant itself perhaps such as a planet Jupiter?
It's an interesting question.
As such,
life especially at a multicellular level,
what have to be considerably different from life here on our planet.
A gas giant like Jupiter for starters probably does not have a solid surface.
It's just atmosphere and atmosphere until you reach a molten core.
Accordingly,
life on a guest join would have to exist in the atmosphere permanently airborne,
and these organisms would have to be able to withstand the pressure and
turbulence of a gas giants atmosphere.
The surface of a guest shine,
especially one like Jupiter,
it would be extremely inhospitable.
No life as we know it could exist.
They're subjected to extreme heat and pressure is so intense that hydrogen is
forced to become a solid.
If single celled life could evolve in an environment like this in motion with no
solid surface and from there multicellular life could possibly evolve,
what would these organisms be like?
Well,
the simplest possibility is perhaps a balloon like organism one which stays
afloat in the atmosphere by inflating itself and adjusting that level of
inflation to move around.
These organisms may be photosynthetic like giant floating plans or since the sun
won't be much dimmer this far out,
they could feed off nutrients in the atmosphere.
These could be massive like the size of cities.
There couldn't be organisms which remain in the atmosphere just long enough only
to reproduce and then sync to the core of the planet having accomplished their
life goal.
There could be hunters in this environment.
There were some equivalent organisms which feed off to floating organisms and
perhaps organisms which feed off of those organisms.
Intelligence though is unlikely.
Very,
very unlikely,
as there is no environment on Jupiter in which intelligence would be necessary.
Furthermore,
even if intelligence did evolve,
there will be no materials in the atmosphere with which to make a civilization.
Therefore,
in my opinion,
it would be astonishing to find Joby and organisms with more than a feeble
bundle of neurons for brain.
The possibilities go on,
but how likely is it for Jupiter itself?
What the majority of Jupiter's atmosphere isn't largely hydrogen with a decent
amount of helium,
but also some traces of some other stuff like water,
carbon,
oxygen,
ammonia,
et cetera.
Could these molecules come together to form life?
Well,
the scarcity of these molecules mixed with the effect that Jupiter is very
radioactive and the atmosphere is rough and turbulent makes it unlikely
impossible.
No,
we're theorizing over,
yes,
worth exploring,
but likely probably not,
but there's still hope for gas giants as a whole.
Smaller guests,
giants have larger amounts of the molecules that will be necessary for life,
ones around the size of Neptune,
Uranus,
and Neptune themselves that probably two in hospital for life,
but exoplanets around that size close to their star especially could potentially
harbor this kind of life.
If you're ready to explore Jupiter and other gas giants for life,
be sure to give this video a like and for more videos on subjects like this and
many other topics,
just
be sure to subscribe to fire of learning.
Thank you for watching.